Hey, Dr. Capacotter is here. We're set up here. You can see we're doing some
fill-beat. We're working at a really cool thing. We're going to be putting
together a course that's based upon my new book, Stop by the Cancer Start Tree and
the Cost. Right, so I see that book. It's been out since 2010. It's true but I've
re-writing it. This edition is going to be really completely new. Different
cover but really different content and with a lot of added information, I think
you're going to love it. What we're doing with it is we're going to put
together it not just as a book. It will be a book you can buy it on it, but it's
going to be an educational series and a course that you can take. That's one of
the things we're building right now. Going over the different supplements that are
in the book, different things that you could do for cancer. We really want it to be
a help. We want the course to be real life, what you could do for your cancer,
because we can see everybody in our clinic. The more people that we can help
that can see us online, that can download the course, download the book. We're going to
continue to give the book away free like we've always done. That's what's all about
and that's what we feel like our mission is. A lot of work and exhausted right in the middle of
a break here because my voice is giving out, but hopefully it's going to be a blast to do a lot of people.